foreign
[Music]
this week we continue to cover the full
range of Hollywood movies and series
news we tell you about a Friday the 13th
reboot why Rick and Morty Creator Justin
Roiland has been dropped from the show
and why the shooting of the current
reality show squid game The Challenge is
anything but safe for the contestants
plus we have summarized the Oscar
nominations and bring you good news on a
Tron sequel as well as violent night 2.
we hope you enjoy the news
in about a month and a half the 95th
Academy Awards better known as the
Oscars will be held in Los Angeles after
the Golden Globes recently gave a
preview of the favorites the nominations
for what is probably the most famous
award in the world of film were now
announced on Tuesday leading the Oscar
nominations is the surprise hit
everything everywhere all at once with
11 nominations it is closely followed by
Martin mcdonas the Banshees of inner
Sharon and the German war film All Quiet
on the Western Front with nine
nominations close behind is baz
luhrmann's Elvis with eight nominations
and Steven Spielberg's the fablemans
with seven movies like top gun Maverick
Avatar the way of water black panther
wakanda forever Babylon and tar can also
hope to win some awards the 95th Academy
Awards will take place on Sunday March
12 2023 are you excited to find out who
the winners are let us know in the
comments
the team around director Tommy orcola
scored a huge success with violent
Knight the Christmas film which was
released on December 2nd 2022 is one of
the more unusual representatives of its
genre and even received an R rating due
to explicit violence the movie was well
received by viewers a specially lead
actor and stranger things Star David
Harbor's performance as the Grim Santa
Claus was impressive unsurprisingly as
the rap reported this week those
responsible are working on a sequel to
their Christmas hit director Ricola
announced that he and returning
screenwriters Pat Casey and Josh Miller
are already discussing the future
development of the sequel in theory
there are plenty of options to further
explore the Violet Knight Universe for
example the Christmas elves and the
North Pole were barely given any
attention it can also be expected that
David Harbor will return in front of the
camera and put his fighting skills to
the test in a Christmas setting once
again whether he might be protecting
another family's home next time or
whether a completely new approach will
be be taken remains to be seen however
fans of the first part should not expect
a release in this pre-Christmas season
because the arrangements will certainly
need some more time we do consider a
release in the coming year to be
realistic though
the website Bloody Disgusting reported
an almost forgotten horror franchise
this week we are talking about the
Friday the 13th franchise with cult
character Jason Voorhees which last
received an installment in 2009 after 14
years of waiting there is now supposed
to be some activity behind the scenes
the first rumors of a new film already
circulated at the end of 2022 according
to the latest developments none other
than Friday the 13th Creator Sean s
Cunningham is said to be responsible for
the production of a reboot he is joined
by the teacher director Jeremy Weiss and
screenwriter Jeff Locker the trio is
also reportedly planning other films for
example another reboot of house from
1986 is also in the pipeline but the
best known project to date is clearly
the planned reboot of the horror classic
about the man with the hockey mask it
would in fact also be the 13th movie in
the series so it would be a very special
anniversary the movie production of
Friday the 13th was unable to start
until iteratively late as a major legal
dispute between Sean s Cunningham and
the original author Victor Miller played
out until the very end should the reboot
not come about due to further disputes a
sequel to the content of the first part
from 1980 is the backup plan of
Cunningham Weiss and mocker so it'll
probably take some time until a possible
theatrical release anyway if you're
already in the mood for a reunion with
Jason Voorhees you shouldn't miss the
upcoming prequel series which was
officially confirmed recently however a
release date has not been announced yet
Ten Years After Tron legacy things are
now heating up for the sequel Tron Ares
as deadline reports negotiations for
Tron 3 are well underway the start of
filming is set for August 2023 and the
Norwegian Joachim roaning is set to take
over Direction he previously directed
Maleficent 2 Mistress of evil and
Pirates of the Caribbean 5 dead men tell
no tales for Disney to name just a few
in the latest project Jared Leto is to
take the lead role it seems that Disney
already got into conversation with the
Hollywood star in 2017 in addition to
the possible director roaning Jesse
wigetau is also involved as a
screenwriter according to deadline his
biggest script happened a while back he
penned the script for Eight Mile with
Eminem it is not known yet whether Jeff
Bridges the star of Tron and Tron legacy
will be returning the Tron film series
started back in 1982 and has always been
known for its funky neon science fiction
look the sequel trying to Legacy grossed
over 400 million dollars worldwide in
2010 so it was only a matter of time
before the next part was tackled we're
looking forward to the next piece of
news and we'll keep you up to date a
release date is not known at the moment
but 2025 seems reasonable should filming
actually begin this fall
Netflix qualifies the accusations when
Netflix first announced a reality show
in the Swim Game format some time ago
the reaction among fans was rather muted
many wondered how exactly the lethal
danger and merciless consequences from
the series could be applied to real
participants an answer to this is being
provided by the filming currently taking
place in the UK as variety reports the
recording of the first episode recently
took place north of London in cold
winter temperatures and has already
caused the first victims according to
the contestants some were unable to
finish the game Red Light Green Light
due to health problems caused by the
extremely cold weather and the rather
sparse equipment provided by Netflix a
total of four contestants had to seek
medical treatment as either the cold
affected their bodies or they sustained
external injuries Netflix officials
promptly responded to the accusations
stressing that thermal underwear and
gloves were provided to each participant
in addition they they denied that anyone
was seriously injured however it was
admitted that it had been very cold that
day which was probably not made any
better giving the filming location and a
huge aircraft Hangar so far 228 out of
456 candidates are said to have made it
through the first round which is just
about half we are looking forward to
more news from the set as the show does
not seem to be too gentle with its
candidates so far by the way there is a
whopping 4.56 million US Dollars up for
grabs so the competitors will be pretty
ruthless especially towards the end of
the season sadly there is still no
information about the premiere of squid
game The Challenge
rumors first surfaced as early as
January 12 2023 that Rick and Morty
Creator Justin Roiland would be charged
with aggravated domestic violence NBC
News reported that criminal charges were
filed against Roiland in May 2020. in
addition to domestic abuse there is also
an accusation of false imprisonment this
is being raised by an ex-partner of
royland for which the 42 year old was
already arrested for a short time and
later let out a bail for royland's
colleagues at Rick and Morty the latest
accusations come at an unfavorable time
as the production of the seventh season
is already in full swing and now has to
look for a new dubbing actor royland was
considered the most important voice
actor who besides other work dubbed the
two main characters and has been in
charge of the series with Dan Harmon
since it started airing in 2013 it will
now be all the more difficult to
adequately cast the two animated
characters after all a large part of the
series humor is based on the character's
quirks and voices to what extent the
production of season 7 will be further
delayed is not entirely clear since a
potential substitute seems not to have
been found yet Roiland on the other hand
should no longer expect to have a future
in the movie business he is now also no
longer a part of his founded game
Company squanch games which recently
released high on life his current
projects solar opposites and koala man
will also have to manage without him in
the future we will keep you posted about
further developments
and that concludes the Weekly News if
you'd like to see more content then take
a look at our new original about Joker
Folia do in addition we also suggest
that you watch the new Shazam Fury of
the Gods trailer we hope you enjoyed our
content as always thanks for watching
and see you next time
foreign
[Music]